everybody is using expressvpn I started
using this when I found out how many
people were buying and selling my data
online for less than seven dollars per
month you can join me and fight back
against big Tech by using expressvpn how
do you think big tech companies like
Twitter make all their money anyway by
tracking your searches video history and
everything you click on and then selling
your personal data expressvpn helps you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your IP address a unique
identifier that every device has that
allows big Tech to match your activity
back to you that's why I use expressvpn
on all my devices to make it much more
difficult for them to exploit my data
for their own profits and the best part
is how easy it is to use the expressvpn
app I just tap one button on my phone or
computer to turn it on and that's all it
takes to keep people out of my business
if you don't like big Tech tracking you
and selling your personal data for
profit it's time to fight back visit
expressvpn.com Tim Dillon right now to
get three months of expressvpn for free
that's expressvpn.com Tim Dillon
expressvpn.com
Tim Dillon ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the Tim Dillon patreon episode uh I
was watching uh the Grammy reaction on
Twitter
um to the
Sam Smith uh
thing that he did
um by the way Madonna looks exactly
get up Bram Stoker's Dracula like
Madonna looks exactly like the dude in
Bram Stoker's Dracula that guy this guy
right here
he Madonna is just
I think there's a certain amount of work
that you can do to the body before the
body just starts fighting it and you
look demonic like something starts
happening where the body starts fighting
the filler and the [__] you put in and
then you end up looking just like a
demon like there's nothing like that
Disturbed me so much more than whatever
Sam Smith is doing to get attention it's
you know the problem with the the right
wing people and the maggot people uh a
lot of times is that
everything is Satanism everything is
Satan and listen Sam Smith is like this
very talented guy who started his career
doing he was thin and he was singing
like really good songs that only works
for a little while you can't keep people
excited about that then he came out as
gay and people were like they don't
really care about that then he came out
as non-binary and they went a little
better then he got fat and they're like
all right we're listening now he's Satan
and they're like ah now we get it's it's
it's it's it's an exercise and by the
way
does this guy when you think of say
first of all you really start to realize
this doesn't work Hollywood does not
work if people are gross it doesn't work
if people are ugly it does not work the
problem with Sam Smith the most
defensive thing is that he's trying to
do all this stuff he looks like a
plumber like Sam Smith looks like a guy
that would [__] show up to fix the
HVAC in your house and he's got devil
horns and he's in like a a [__] you
know a red onesie and he's jumping
around if you're gonna sell this
androgynous [__] you gotta have a David
Bowie Charisma you have to have a little
magic about you Harry Styles gets near
that but it's not Bowie like Harry
Styles is kind of like the knockoff
Bowie but Sam Smith I mean looks like my
uncle at a [__] Halloween party like
it's and everyone's like it's satanic
it's Satan this is like plastic devil
horns on a hat he looks like like the
the fat guy at a Halloween party who's
had too much to drink and he's jumping
around with these people I I just I I
can't the rage that the right wing
caught like constantly has about like
everybody said every year someone does
something
to uh evoke like the idea of the devil
this is not new Nicki Minaj did it I'm
sure Gaga's done something like
everybody does it and every time they do
it uh people go they're taking our kids
which no children are watching the
Grammys nobody's watching the Grammys
except maybe these right-wing Christian
people to get angry but this is like
this is the same energy that when your
mom was like
you you you can't go to the Hot Topic in
the mall because like the girl who works
there's a Satanist it's like no she's a
fat chick with a dog collar that's what
she is it's not there's nothing past it
other than that like it's like I don't
know what Sam Smith believes in I don't
think he believes in anything probably
except attention which she gets this is
all about attention and the quickest way
to get attention is not to make good
music which that song is good at the
body say it's a catchy song and you know
people in the right wing they can't do
that they they get mad that the people
that disagree with them make kind of
good [__] you know they could have tried
you know got the fizer shot now he's
dead in the hallway like they but their
rage at this stuff is just like this is
not this is just
kind of embarrassing like it just shows
you that Hollywood is an image business
that's all it's ever been it's been hot
people some of them are talented some of
them are not but usually they've been
relatively attractive and what bothers
people like he's got this new music
video where he's like jumping around and
he's got pasties on his nipples and
again people are nowhere near as
offended by this if it's not if it he
doesn't look like the Michelin Man
that's why it's confusing to people
don't understand they go if you're gonna
do Satan [__] shouldn't it at least be
sexy
[__] like there's no tolerance for like
a fat androgynous Satanist in this
country there's just none there's none
you're asking people to accept too many
things at once you know these people are
just trying to be [__] edgy they're
trying to get attention you know people
are like well my kids are watching it's
like well then why are they why are they
watching it tell them not to watch it it
also looks cartoonish
it doesn't look like like
a Catholic mass he seems more satanic
than this you know with chanting and
incense and [__] hush tones and the
Gregorian [__] like this seems again
like chubby chicks at the Hot Topic are
now the biggest stars in the country
that's the problem the people I mean
this is what someone would wear at a
mall to get a tent like usually like one
or two people dress like this in an
award show be like one or two people
came in looking like look insane to make
their point now it's like every person
is dressed like they they got out of a
Halloween store
and it it's it's crazy and I get it I
get if you're in Middle America go what
the [__] is this what is this I
understand that it's just the the rage
about like the satanists are coming for
our kid it's like these people are fat
chicks from the Hot Topic with dog
collars on we just made them faint like
that's the aesthetic now that famous Sam
Smith started as a normal guy singing
but he's like if I want real attention I
have to become a fat chick from The Hot
Topic with a dog collar on because
everyone's gonna say it's beautiful and
brave and everybody's gonna love me and
I'm making these statements for body
positivity and whatever else and you
know it's confusing to people it's confu
people have to understand why you're a
star
they have to get it they have to look at
you and go that person is better than me
they have to feel that in their bones
they have to look at somebody you look
at Beyonce you go Beyonce's better than
me she's more attractive than me she's a
better singer than me
um And when they see Sam Smith he
obviously is a great singer and the
music is catchy but this appearance
where it's constantly just like he looks
like the the newest video he I mean he
looks like such a [__] mess with the
get the video up where he's got pasties
on his tits and I don't even know what
he's wearing I mean it looks he looks
like he's in like a hospital gown
people are people are so offended by it
it's it's insane looking
I don't even think that people are like
people just don't even understand what's
happening
it's you know
it's not even that people are homophobic
or transphobic they're confused
everybody doesn't understand
why a guy who looks like a plumber is
wearing like some Elizabethan [__]
like I don't even know like he's wearing
a half of like a Victorian era house
dress with pasties on his tits he's got
a CR it's just too much for people
it's too much it's like
I don't even know what to say anymore
about any of this like I I I I I'm kind
of tapping out like I I the culture is
no longer interesting to talk about
really it's not it maybe we'll end the
show like I I mean to be honest it's
like at a certain point the the the
culture is just rotted to the point
where like on every side of everything
there's nothing there's no take to have
here this is what it is shut it off if
you don't like it don't watch it this is
what it's gonna be you know what are you
gonna change any of this they they want
fat God plumbers and would paste these
on their tits to jump around no one's
hot anymore no one's good looking the
more disgusting you are the better it is
this is what they want
so I you know and then the other side
thinks everyone's trying to [__] their
kids and no one really is trying to [__]
their kids Sam Smith is probably not
trying to [__] your children he's just
trying to make more money from this
nightmare that we're in and he's doing a
good job of it but like there's not much
there's not much to gain here from like
constantly
having this fight let them have this
there is no one culture there is no one
thing your kids don't have to watch this
they don't have to see it you can keep
them from it if you can't keep them from
it you're a bad parent if you can't keep
your kids from seeing Sam and you know
what listen if your kids see this and
they start dressing like this well then
you know then you've not done a great
job I guess or if they start dressing
like this and start making millions well
then [__] it that's good that's great
maybe this is how they have to compete
in the new world like there's there's
really not anything about this that that
is interesting at all none of this is
interesting like the fact that people
care at all about the Grammys and it
bothers them that people jump around in
Devil can't like just stop who can't
like there's nothing about this that has
any meaning it's not it's it's
meaningless
and then people keep trying to give it
meaning they're invoking Satan Satan
doesn't want to be involved in this
it's like it's just it's embarrassed I'm
embarrassed for the country I don't know
why people come here truly I think maybe
less I understand if you're like Mexican
and you live whatever you're out running
the cartels like life's horrible and all
these other places this country's in a
an Abomination it's an embarrassment and
an Abomination and I don't know what's
left to even do really I mean like move
if you can leave America leave America
there's better places to live like the
UK is a better run country in every
respect it's I talked to Shane Gillis
about it we were like yeah it's kind of
embarrassing when you go over there and
you're like rah-rah America then you get
there and you're like oh yeah you guys I
mean it's gray and it rains but it's a
better country it's a better country the
way it's set up for people for most
people to live not if you're a
multi-millionaire not if you're a
[__] rich but you're not for the most
part so it's just like uh yeah I mean is
this we don't don't have uh you know we
don't have any
like
there's we don't have a purpose we don't
have a reason to exist are you ready for
the biggest Sunday in sports DraftKings
sports book an official sports betting
partner of Super Bowl 57 has all the
Super Bowl action you need new customers
can bet you it's five dollars and get
200 and free bets instantly plus all
customers can get in on the Super Bowl
57 excitement with DraftKings happy hour
super boosts
check the DraftKings Sportsbook every
day between 6 p.m to 9 P.M to see what
prop bet will be boosted I'm telling you
guys this is the best sports betting
website you can go to download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app and use code
Tim Dillon new customers can bet five
dollars on Super Bowl 57 you'll get 200
in free bets instantly only at draftking
Sportsbook with code Tim d-i-l-l-o-n
I'm going with the Eagles I like people
from Philadelphia they have hard lives
and they deserve more minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply void in
Ohio gambling problem call 8778 Hope New
York tax Hope New York 467-369 New York
this is the best sports betting website
to use DraftKings Sportsbook is a
trusted partner of the show we really
appreciate them and I hope you guys go
out there and win hello everybody let's
talk about athletic greens this is the
best supplement you can take
I've taken it it keeps everybody healthy
uh it's great for your gut it's easy to
fit into your lifestyle you can take
this one thing instead of a bunch of
different things
um it was designed with ease in mind so
you can live healthier and better
without having to do a lot
I'm always looking for life hacks and
you know I I mean athletic greens is
like number one
it's an all-in-one formula that makes it
easy for me to cover my nutritional
bases every single day every scoop is
packed with 75 vitamins minerals and
Whole Food Source ingredients of the
highest quality that gives me major
benefits like mood support boosted
energy a healthier gut healthier looking
skin hair and nails
if you're looking for an easier way to
take supplements athletic creams is
giving away a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to
athleticqueens.com Tim Dillon that's
athleticgreens.com Tim Dillon and check
it out there's no reason that we all
exist here except to do drugs and get
fat and [__] blame each other for
this nightmare that we've all created
leave I mean just get out that the
message of my new my new uh comedy is
about telling people to get out of here
just leave
I heard so many stories from behind the
scenes of the Grammys people are
fighting each other people didn't want
to show up people were angry it's like
it
stop you know
just let them hat this is what they want
they've earned this let them worship
Satan that's the other thing who cares
if they worship Satan it's not your
business that they worship say and
they're not worshiping Satan that's the
other thing it's like people don't even
understand what Satanism is it's not
even about worshiping Satan the whole
religion of Satanism is about ego
gratification or whatever I always
thought it was [__] I you have the
one no part of it but like then there
are legit luciferian people that believe
all these whatever things but they're
just trying to make money you dumb [__]
that's all they're trying to do like
they don't this idea satanists probably
have principles these people have no
principle satanists would look at these
people and go please stay away from us
please stay away from us these people
have no principle they have no
principles there is nothing behind their
eyes I think it's it's nicer to feel
like they're evil evil people have
principles they're doing evil people
that have nothing behind their eyes
absolutely nothing it's like scary I
think that's that's what really scares
people is out banal and [__] mediocre
and and and and and corporate and boring
this [__] culture is it is a boring
culture where in order to get attention
this slob has to go out and dress like
some [__] wizard and jump around with
these other idiots it's like it's a boy
it's a culture with nothing left there
is nothing left to get attention there
is no place left to go with there's no
place left to go it's like they're not
they're wearing like these cartoonish
devil horns and these like red top hats
they know exactly who's gonna get mad
they know it's gonna Trend worldwide on
Twitter
everybody knows they did this thing this
demonic thing I'm the team the song's
called Unholy I'm a demon look at me I'm
a demon well I'm a demon aren't you mad
at that aren't you mad at that the
people angry at this can't go to the
doctor they have no ability to go to the
doctor and get medicine and the reason
that they don't have that ability is
because this is what they pay attention
to they're all fighting for this they're
mad at this fat mechanic who is somehow
convinced them that he's like this
satanic [__] you know
it's just boring it's boring the whole
culture is boring it's it's like there's
nothing worth there's nothing worth it
we should get nuked I mean really if if
if if if we got nuked it would make
things interesting because at least we
could recover from it and talk about it
so I'm asking you if you are a country
out there that has the ability to Nuke
America please do it just because it
will make the art better it would make
the art better if people were walking
around here uh with uh like uh like
people from that movie
um uh The Hills Have Eyes like if we had
like nuclear mutants and we had to deal
with that and and and that would be more
interesting to me than any of this [__]
I'm for nuking America I'm for nuking
the United States remember for the sake
of art just for the sake of art I don't
have any problem per se with the people
but for the sake of art please attack us
please attack us
we need we need a war we need Wars maybe
they know maybe the ruling class of this
country just knows better than we do and
they're like we need a war here because
these people it's such a meaningless
pile of garbage every day then nothing
would be better for this country than a
massive Invasion by China and I believe
that nothing would be better than seeing
cities get blown to bits by a foreign
Invader because we would stop talking
about all this [__]
it would be imagine that if China
attacked the Grammy Awards what a great
what a great
pivot what a great pivot from where we
are now the the culture has been
strained to the point where the only
thing left is is is is really people
need something to fight for that has
meaning
so we need a war culture reset
we need a serious War we need a serious
years-long war and it needs to be bloody
and people have to die and that's all
that we're ever that's all that will fix
it I truly believe this this is a fat
dumb country of disgusting people that
needs to be really it needs to be
challenged with a with a great anime
like China
that's all that that's all I have to say
about all this uh you know because it's
it's it's boring we've made the chubby
girl at the Hot Topic famous we've made
the fat girl from the mall famous and
now we're acting like she's the greatest
threat to us can you imagine that can
you imagine making the fat girl with the
dog collar from the Hot Topic famous and
saying that's what everyone should be
and that's what everyone should look
like I mean that's where we're at we've
reached we're we're way past Peak we're
way past anything it will only get worse
it will only degenerate further unless
we have a multi-year war with China and
Russia that wipes out half of the
population
and I I'm not saying it'll be nice I
might die I'm sure I would I'm sure a
lot of people would die and I'm not
trying to bum anyone out I'm strictly
saying if we do not get nuked we're in
trouble
we are in trouble without a good nuking
a good new king we need if there's ever
been a country that needs a nuking right
now we need a new king we need 10 9 11 9
11 will not even do it we need 9 11's
every day for a year every day for a
year another 911 in a major American
city just to get us back to where we
need to be
foreign
that's a fact that's a fact and the
demons that run this place the real ones
not the ones with thick [__] fake
Carnival hats on the real demons that
that wear suits every day and sit in
bunkers know we need it they know we
need it that's why they keep going to
rush they're going idiot they know we
need it they know we need it
that's my feeling about the Sam Smith
thing is that like culture is
degenerated to the point where we are no
longer uh able to produce anything of
that nothing of value culturally is
produced in this country anymore
everything is an embarrassment to the
point where we're really not on this
show I'm gonna try to move on and not
discuss any of it really because I don't
know what else there is to say I don't
want to be part of the chorus of people
discussing this garbage because it's
just frankly it's I'm embarrassed for
this country in a way that I've never
been embarrassed I'm like deeply ashamed
to be a part of this in any way to be a
part of this media landscape in any way
truly in whatever it's called to have to
talk about this horse [__] and to
[__] have to have a take on it and
talk and go yeah well there's that guy
say not a paper
he's Satan and he's got a the trans girl
with him who's like awesome Germany all
grew up in Germany and nobody knew I was
and it's all it's all ridiculous they're
all they're all very wealthy people they
give each other trophies everybody's on
crack everybody's on major major drugs
at the Grammys by the way they're all on
major drugs they have to shoot them up
with drugs to get them into the limos
they have to get them out they have to
they have to argue with them to even get
them to perform because they're so
they're on crack they're fighting each
other in the back uh you know and they
were always on drugs but at least from
that came good [__] now it's like the
weakest most mediocre slime it's just
slime and uh there's just nowhere to go
there's nowhere to go so if your kids
are offended by this I'm sorry kill them
because this is where they're growing up
this is where they're growing up you
could try to keep it but this is whether
they're going to grow up in a country
where the the fat chick from The Hot
Topic is the biggest star we're going to
make the fat girl with the dog collar
from the Hot Topic who cut herself the
biggest star in the country and they're
going to do movies about her and they're
gonna do pieces about her and they're
gonna talk about how Brave she is to
[__] eat and [__] get do drugs and
[__] suck guys off in a parking lot
on a Hot Topic and that's all we've got
left that's really all we have left so
if any of it offends you and if you're
offended by my suggestion that we need
to be nuked and someone will clip this
and try to get me in trouble I don't
give a [__] it's purely for the purposes
of art that I suggest we be in a major
war
that's all nobody in turkey's talking
about this they just had a [__]
earthquake
so that that's what we need we need we
and hopefully we get it and and if not a
nuking a real climate disaster you know
that could be good too like some real
serious climate disasters
um and then maybe we can make movies
about them because we're we're just
we're at the bottom of the barrel here
when this is all you have to do to be at
your all you have to do to be edgy is is
do wear red and jump around and go I'm
I'm the devil see look at me and then
everyone's like there's Satan Satan is
coming it's like will you stop please
this is a country that like denies
operations for two-year-olds on a
regular basis and tells them to [__] off
and they die and this fat guy with a
[__] Carnival hat a [__] plastic
hat
is is because he's evil now he's evil
the fat guy with the carnival hat and
and every you know and all these junkies
that jump around you know and these are
the problems right you know we've got
the I don't know man I'm just I'm just
kind of disgusted by all I need a
vacation to be honest I need a break
I've been talking to microphone for too
[__] long I don't care I just don't I
don't know how anyone cares about
anything anymore I don't understand shut
it off people with kids shut it off
Jesus Christ stop pretending you care
that much about your shut it off
take the well my kids on the internet
get them off the internet take their
phone they don't need a phone take the
phone take the phone away
but then they have to parent see that's
what nobody wants nobody wants to parent
their children so they go no I'm
supposed to give them a phone so they
can go and [__] off all day while I get
drunk and not parent them and I'm I'm
just I want everything on that phone to
line up with my values take the phone
get them off and parent them if it's
that [__] hard don't have kids how
about that don't demand that the junkie
drug addict slime that runs rampant in
this universe is going to have all of
the same values as you
what are you nuts how dumb are you
people well I just I hope the Grammy
Awards have the values that are good for
my children what
are you on crack all right what else
there's got to be go somewhere else I'm
sick of this I'm sick of this country I
hope it gets bombed I hope it gets
bombed I hope it gets bombed to the
brink of Extinction and then and then it
would be
um
what is this Disney backs reparations
um okay good and again who cares like
this is like what a nightmare
they have a cartoon that says why people
suck stop why okay I don't you know this
is the new thing Disney does where
they've gone super well it's like okay
you know
watch another cartoon watch another
cartoon that doesn't do that or is there
no other cartoon where black people
um Don't lecture white people if that's
your problem if you have a problem with
your kids getting lectured too by black
cartoon characters don't watch it how
about that don't watch it
it's like it's just a mill of nonsense
that people have to be like my kids are
getting told they're demons and what
then don't then don't let why are you
watching it
isn't Disney the [__] thing you all
hate anyway
woke Disney Sparks outrage with new kids
cartoon that claims America was built on
slavery as it pushes reparations and
says Lincoln had no desire to liberate
things that your kids don't know who
Lincoln is
your kids do not know who Lincoln is
it's called The Proud Family louder and
prouder has sparked outrage by showing
the characters discovering that their
town was built by slaves and they're
giving a presentation of their school
in California a reparations boards
insisting that every long-term black
resident gets 5 million in reparations
okay that won't happen aboard aboard a
board a board said it a board said it so
it now let's fight about it let's have
30 million articles about the five
million dollars that nobody's gonna get
from California okay I just don't have
like I I I don't have this fight in me
anymore this this country is becoming
just truly miserable people trying to
make everybody's life worse
the investment in an overall misery in
this country and the internet has just
becoming a factory of misery that's what
it is it's just a factory of people who
want to be angry all the time at
everything on all sides and people who
refuse to create a a a moral Universe
for them and their family and then
[__] depend on Disney to do it like
they depend on Disney to raise their
kids so when Disney does things they
don't like they go well [__] that yeah I
don't know make your own movies how
about that make your own films
make your own films that talk about the
American history you want to teach your
kids do a film where you don't your kids
don't have to watch uh Disney movies
that have a budget of 100 million
dollars you could you know what my
godson watches [__] animal videos
they're just videos of animals walking
around yards he's fine with that he
doesn't need to watch Avatar he can what
just put on Animal Planet have they gone
woke
has the Platypus is lecturing you about
trans rights just watch Animal Planet
are people now claiming animal planets
woke no I was just double checking on
the internet I want to make sure but
this is really like
it's gotten to a point now where
everybody goes I'm mad there's nothing
for my kids to watch we'll read them a
book hey I got an idea read them a
[__] book how about that put your
pills down and read them a book but you
don't want to do that because you want
to watch Tucker Carlson or you want to
watch that so you want to sit your kids
in front of the tablet this is the
problem now we've just wanted to sit
people in front of a television or a
computer and not do anything and then
have these corporations raise them well
that doesn't work and you're seeing why
it doesn't work because kids shouldn't
be told when they're young that they're
oppressors and that they've done the
wrong thing or that there's 95 genders
like it's not good for kids to learn all
that but instead of trying to fight
Disney World how about you just read
your kid of [__] The Chronicles of
Narnia and put them to bed
well they go over their French houses
and it's on their friend TV well then
don't let them do that but then but but
well then fine they don't have friends
get them guns they don't need friends if
they have guns
I'm just sick I'm really just sick of
like this idea that like you you're
depending on these corporations to raise
your [__] children and when they do
something you know these corporations
only want to make [__] money they're
not they don't care about your kids they
don't care about family values they
never have news flash they never have
it's never been what's animated or
motivated these people they just want to
make [__] money so opt out opt out of
the [__] system don't have your kids
watch it read them [__] books and
when they're old enough to make their
own decisions that's fine well it's not
as easy as that you don't have kids easy
for you to say yeah I know it's not as
easy as that nothing's easy blue tube
baby what is left to say about Bluetooth
remember the days when you were always
ready to go don't be that guy that says
I don't need it you don't know until you
try it you could be missing out on the
best sex of your life with Bluetooth
first impressions are important how
about Lasting Impressions
Bluetooth is really phenomenal it helps
you it's a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra Cialis and Levitra but it's in a
chewable tablet and it's at a fraction
at the cost sign up at bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days
go to bluetooth.com promo code TD to
receive your first month free go to
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
we thank Bluetooth for sponsoring the
podcast again go to bluetooth.com promo
code TD to receive your first month free
hello fresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hello fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's America's number one meal kit
I'm telling you all those New Year's
goals oh I'm gonna get in better shape
I'm going to cook more I'm Gonna Save
money hellofresh allows you to
accomplish all of those goals they have
40 weekly recipes to choose from you can
say bye bye to your recipe rut and treat
yourself and your family to exciting new
flavors every week looking for an easy
way to eat well and save money cut back
on expensive takeout and delivery and
get started with hello fresh
you'll love how fast easy and affordable
it is to whip up a restaurant quality
meal right in your own kitchen I'm
telling you I use it I love it they
deliver it well I'll make something and
everybody loves it go to hellofresh.com
timd65 use the code timd65 for 65 off
plus free shipping
go to hellofresh.com
timd65 use code timd65 for 65 off plus
free shipping raising kids ain't easy it
wasn't supposed to be who told you it
was going to be easy it's not easy my
friends have children and
there's enough [__] for them to watch I
go over their houses their kids are
watching stuff and they're not watching
this [__] so there's other stuff to
watch by the way there's other things
for your children to watch then the
reparations cartoon or Fat Sam Smith and
his [__] Satan dance there's other
things for them to watch we do nothing
in this country except make crap that
you can watch and you can sit your kids
in front of I think it's just like
it's a little weird to me that nobody
wants to take any responsibility for the
content that their children consume they
just don't like that that content exists
and then certain parents are going to
love it they're going to sit their kids
in front of it and they're gonna go
we're watching you're a white demon
today and they're gonna watch that
cartoon and who knows we don't know how
they'll grow up we'll see let's see we
don't know we don't have all the
information but it doesn't mean you know
I just could I just sick of this talk
with these kids will care about the kids
we'll care about these it's these It's
Magic children that everyone cares about
and then it's like all you read about is
that they hold none of them like a lot
of them don't have food or [__] just
like homeless kids what about the
homeless children nobody cares about
them
get them out of the air it's like what
about the Homeless Cat what about the
kids who don't have TVs or computers to
be worried all about them we worrying
all at all about the children who don't
have any material things or are we
worrying simply about one Disney cartoon
that's a little uh you know
uncomfortable
for people and uh I don't know
I want the country to get nuked
I won a nuclear war bad I wanna I mean
maybe we can make it happen here I want
a nuclear exchange how exciting would
you think about it think about it now
everybody go with me on this here
how exciting would it be to hear that
Russia just fired and we've all got
eight minutes and we don't know who's
gonna get it
how much better would your life be if
you knew there were nuclear missiles
sailing right now to this country to
shake everybody out of there wouldn't
that be great wouldn't that be enjoyable
anyway it'd be a wild eight minutes
would it I don't think it would I don't
think it would be a wild eight minutes I
think people would go back to fighting
about a cartoon that's what the people
wouldn't know no no no it would not be a
while they made it it would be people
would go well this is what happens and
then the people on the left would be
like [__] white man outside the
shelter must be organized by you know
it's like it's it's just boring it's a
boring cut leave the dude when you go to
Europe you go to these other country
it's just you've seen what a disaster
we've created here nobody cares about
anything in those places it's it's
lovely they go to the beach they drink
wine they eat there like you know we're
not the only people on Earth by the way
like there's many other countries that
are just fine they're like fine and it's
like we think we're the only people that
matter we're a country of schizophrenics
everyone sees this as a country we're
like a schizophrenic aunt that has a lot
of money now that's like nuts that like
shows up to the party we're like a
schizophrenic aunt who's on pills and
who's fat and she's got a shitload of
money and nobody really knows why I and
she claimed she did it's all because
she's a genius but you go some of it she
did some good things but some of it you
know she took a lot of her husband's
money whatever she stole some of that
money and then like everyone else is
just kind of drinking wine and she's the
aunt who comes in and she goes you want
to start a business and all the kids are
like hey man it's Christmas like we're
just relaxing and she's like what do you
want to be when you grow up and you go I
don't know we're we're just running this
train set and she's like what if you
want to make money like me
you go I don't know maybe I'll find a
girlfriend or something well you got to
make a lot of money that's what we are
in the world we've become like an
annoying disgusting fat ant isn't she
happy in her own mind though
no no
we're hap do you think this country's
happy this is the least happy place I've
been ever America even when people are
happy here they're not they're like
they're it's Mania they're not just
happy they're like Matic no one's happy
in America they're manic like if
someone's happy about something like
that I
got the job I got to take up it's manic
it's not it's not like happy people it's
like [__] manic Psychopaths just
running around or people that are so
depressed they're just [__] jumping
out of Windows there's no like
I've just had it today I've had it the
radio in my Bentley didn't work and I
had to drive around with no radio and I
was [__] angry because I hate that
I was just reading tweets at every
stoplight about this [__] nonsense
and I just I just got so [__] angry
it's so it it just angers me sometimes
and I I don't want people to think it's
negative that I'm suggesting that a
nuclear war would help us I'm just
saying we need something
we do we we need something we need it
now
we need it we need it now Vladimir make
it happen I'm just saying we need we
need something we need some this
country's Rod it's rotted to its core
it's an embarrassment it's right and I
love America and that's why I want it to
be better but it's rotted to its core
it's like nobody's good at anything
nobody can do anything uh you know the
best we can do is put this plumber out
there in a Satan outfit to jump around
and then have people scream and yell
that he like it's infected their
children's Minds you know it's like it
it's it's boring it's bad it's bad
everything's bad
even that new Beyonce album it's okay
it's good but it's not amazing I know
her fans will get upset about that
probably but it's not amazing she's good
she's great she's phenomenal but the new
album's fine you know and it's just like
it's just fine it's all fine and the
investment in it being good let's just
let's just let's just stop to try to
make it good let's just don't get upset
that it's not good don't get upset that
it's not good
be happy you have kids be happy with
your family read them books man read the
[__] kids books uh these these these
[__] arguments we're all getting in
they're all stupid I I just need to
leave this country for a month it's so
amazing when you leave this car you've
been out of the country with me one time
and you've also been out of the car it's
like
it's just getting to a point now where
it's like it's just the insanity of
everything has got it's no longer funny
it's no longer fun to talk about it's
kind of like boring and I don't know
it's just you I read the news all the
time I've been talking about the news
for seven [__] years and nothing
changed nothing nothing changes I'm
telling you nothing [__] my father
said to me once he went yeah nothing
changes since the 60s he goes nothing
really he goes like the internet and
stuff's different but he's like the [__]
people fight about it's the same [__] my
father's checked out he's checked I no
longer pays attention to anything he
pets his dogs he'll play golf he doesn't
care that's the only way to it's the
only way to get by it's the only way to
get buys to truly check out not care
don't spy balloon don't read the article
don't read the article yeah spy balloons
are everywhere who cares will they catch
you jerking off like whatever just
ignore I mean if you get to a point with
all this [__] where it's just like we
need to detox we should delete Twitter
Twitter should be deleted they should
delete all this [__] and people need to
go back outside and people need to
because at the end of the day it's it's
just this has become a nightmare every
day it's a nightmare when you go on the
Internet it's just like a no it's like
it's a factory of Horrors and it's you
know I I don't even know anymore I don't
even go is there is there something
about a terminal illness or something
that's happening
somebody who can get out of this country
something that that's that's good
is there can we help turkey
what about by the way you know what I'm
a huge fan of now Oregon is just killing
everyone I love this organ is letting
people come to their state and die and
by the way how cool is that they're just
letting people who are fed up with
reading about the Spy balloon kill
themselves in Oregon and Oregon's a
great place to die not a great place to
live too but too overcast but it's a
great place to die Oregon becomes
America's first death tourism
destination with one Dr Death offering
terminally ill people from out of state
A Deadly cocktail of drugs at his
assistant suicide clinic by the way I
don't even think you should have to be
terminally ill to to go to Oregon to get
killed I think you should be able to
just write a little essay and go I've
had enough of the Spy balloon and and
and the [__] fat guy with the devil
horns I don't I and I can't I cannot
afford to move so I just want to leave
um I don't know are they trying to make
this bad I mean I was a little with the
Canada thing that was a little much
right where they were just killing they
were letting teenagers kill themselves
that seemed a little much but like if
you have a bad day in Canada you could
literally just write a note and say I
want out and they'll put you out
but um
yeah I mean who cared like
I don't understand why people care that
other people are ending their lives with
terminal like this is the most insane
this country is so insane it's like
someone's suffering horribly and
somebody else is like you better not die
you better stay here why are you gonna
give them any money no
I mean I I just I don't know man I I
just can't I mean I truly need a
vacation I really need to not think
about any of this for for a while I'm
sick of talking about it I'm I'm sick of
everything I I want to leave and go to
like another country somewhere like
Florida where you can just go and sit on
a beach and that's the beauty and the I
love Florida everyone's talking about
I'm not bad Florida is how intolerant
they are and they're burning the books
no one reads the books so No One's Gonna
notice number one number two all you
have left is nature just sit on the
beach and and just get drunk relapse if
you are sober now go and smoke crack I
mean truly and I mean I'm not I'm not
advocating that but I'm telling you if
you feel like it's the right time to
start shooting heroin this is the right
time now I mean this is like I've been
sober for 12 years every day I wake up
and I go should I start smoking crack
like rock cocaine you know that'll be a
great way to just end my career to just
go out big like just become a crack
addict and just run around doing things
that crack addicts do you know I mean it
seems like uh
it seems fun I don't want people to feel
like I'm being too negative but that's
just um
that's just the way I feel I'm sick of
I'm sick of uh commenting on any of this
[__] and um it's gotten to a point where
uh the news is killing everyone I feel
like I'm a part of that I don't want to
be a part of it
um it's destroying life on Earth
and um that's where we're at and the
happiest people I know barely pay
attention to any of this [__] like
they're happy but I can't because it's
like my job so I have to go Jennifer
Lopez snaps and husband Ben Affleck at
the Grammy Awards before recovering
after realizing moment was caught off
camera oh
I hope they kill each other I hope
Jennifer Lopez and Ben Affleck kill each
other in a suicide pact and they blow
each other's brains out I hope they kill
each other
I mean wouldn't that be good for just a
couple like that to kill each other
people have to realize that money and
fame aren't great and the best way for
them to realize that would be for Ben
Affleck and Jennifer Lopez to shoot each
other in the face in a Beverly Hills
restaurant like in a in the middle of
dinner they should just get up and they
should make a suicide pact like that
family did I talked about last week and
they should do it publicly in a
restaurant where they stand up and freak
people out a little bit too like sing a
song sing like an old sea shanty that
nobody's even heard you know like 99
bottles of beer on the wall and then
just put the guns to each other's heads
and blow and and things like that I
think we need kind of stuff like that to
start happening where it's like Kanye
becoming a Nazi was a help that was good
like things like that I think more
moving is in the right direction but you
know Jennifer Lopez and Ben Affleck
having a suicide pack and shooting each
other in the head
um in a uh crowded Beverly Hills
restaurant after singing like a song
happy birthday
to you and then everyone would be
clapping you know because they'd be like
oh they're famous and they're singing
and then they just go and they blow each
other's heads off and that would be
great see I'll talk about stuff like
that that's what I want to talk I want
to talk about real news I want to talk
about real fun stuff where people are
like what I was [__] dude I was three
tables away I was eating calamari and
Jennifer Lopez's brain matter hit my
thing why did they shoot each other I
don't understand they seemed like they
had it all they seemed like they were so
happy why would they make a suicide
packet why would they shoot each other
in a crowded restaurant it's crazy I
don't know maybe we're all living wrong
maybe
maybe we all have the wrong values we
need stuff like that to happen so that
people can go oh yeah maybe uh maybe
it's not that good at the top I don't
know but
you know I I hope that uh Sam Smith gets
whatever uh he wants out of uh this and
I'm sure he will and I'm sure the people
that are angry with him are going to get
out it's just it's just something to do
for the day just something to do for the
day let's yell about the fat girl with
the dog collar from Hot Topic who's now
a star
will scream we'll yell they Satan as
you're coming we're arguing they'll get
mad and then and they're not
all together incorrect they just have it
within their power
to not let their kids watch garbage you
don't have to let your children watch
[__] and I know that that's unpopular
because it requires a lot more effort on
the part of the parents but at the end
of the day you know this is your [__]
job is to make sure your kids and maybe
some of your kids are going to like it
because they're fat satanists some of
your kids are fat satanists and you
don't even know it and you can't stop
them from being fat trans satanists
that's it
you're gonna have to accept it you're
gonna have to accept that some of your
children are fat trans satanists
and you can choose whether to love them
or not you don't have to love them a lot
of people don't love their kids but some
of your children you're looking at them
right now and some of you know you know
in your heart you're looking at a child
and it may be three but you're going I
have a funny feeling that they are a fat
trans Satanist that's the only thing
that'll make them happy and
you just have to
you have to deal with that you have to
deal with the fact that you're not going
to be able to control your children's
lives completely I think that's another
thing that people are like well we're
gonna have to make sure like your life
is not at all like the life your kid is
going to have the amount of information
they're going to have is it's it's
changed the game the amount of
information that's going to be [__]
not true they're gonna have to weed
through it on their own they're gonna
have to figure out what to believe in
and why they're going to have to create
a life for themselves you're not going
to be able to help them do that that
much you're going to be you can't
shelter them from everything and some of
them are fat
trans satanists
truly and that's the only way they're
going to be happy and you're going to
have to be okay with that and you're
gonna have to say to your friend Bob
who goes houses Ashley how's Ashley
doing Bob
she's doing great she's a fat trans
Satanist and we love her
oh well that's good she was always a
special girl she's not a girl Bob they
are not a girl they are a fat trans
Satanist they believe in the dark lord
they believe in eating carbohydrates and
and they believe that they were born in
their own body and that's it you know
it's easy to love your kids if they're
exactly like you it's hard to maybe love
them if they're morbidly obese
trans satanists but many of them will
that's going to be
probably by the time
in the people that have kids now that
are like 10 by the time those kids are
18 everybody will be a fat trans
Satanist
the people that aren't will be freaks
they will be
ostracized from society in ways you
cannot imagine they will be it'll be
like Jim Crow laws for people that are
not
sat trans say you should make your
children into fat trans satanists if you
are a good parent
you should have every every night you go
to your kid you go listen
you eat as much ice cream as you want
and you'd be any gender you want and
we're going to worship Satan in this
house
because I want you to have the tools
to succeed I want you to have the tools
to succeed I work hard every day to put
food on this table so that you can be
fat
I work hard every day so that you can
pick a gender and I work hard every day
so that you can live your life according
to the laws of the dark lord Lucifer
Satan who is your real father
so I mean that's that's the thing
it's not even shocking anymore I'm not
shocked I'm so not shocked by anything
anymore
if I walked into a Starbucks and
somebody was standing behind the counter
and they had like devil horns implanted
in their head and they were 900 pounds
and they were wearing a cape I would
just say can I have a double tall
non-fat latte so I can sit in this
[__] dump and read about the Chinese
balloon that spies on us all
and that person would nod with their
horns and then they would go and they
would make the drink and then it would
go Tim and I'd go yes I go thanks so
much and they would smile because it's
fun to be a fat trans Satanist
and that's what it is and if Republicans
are smart
they will run a fat trans Satanist who
believes in capitalism
and you will have someone come out
that's 400 pounds with devil horns who's
trans and has pasties on their nips and
get out and start talking about the
importance of low corporate taxes and
the police you're not going to win Here
No One's Gonna Win everyone will be a
fat trans Satanist there's nothing you
can do about it you can get on board now
or you you might not want to get on
board but that's okay because it looks
fun
and you're not pitching anything that
looks fun that's the problem being in
morbidly obese trans Satanist seems to
be the only way to have any fun in this
country anymore
so
that's it we're creating a culture where
the top of the food chain will be the
fat girl who wears a dog collar at Hot
Topic at the mall who's putting onion
rings in her ass
that's the king now that's the top of
the charts she can get on board or not
or you or or or you could read your
children The Chronicles of Narnia
how about that it's a good book it's
about Aslan The Lion The Witch the
Wardrobe
you could read them the book and here's
what I think will happen here's what I
think will happen I think you'll start
to read the kid the book I think you'll
get a chapter in and then you'll go you
know what
just be a fat trans Satanist I can't
there's how many books in the series six
there's six books
just be a fat trans Satanist I don't
have the time I want to go out I want to
have a couple of Pops I don't have the
time just just what are you gonna be 300
pounds and worship Satan in the living
room great I don't have to read to you
perfect perfect that's perfect that's
fine you'll start out you'll get like
nine pages in you'll see that they're
not paying attention because they don't
have the ability to pay attention
anymore and you'll just go huh well
I guess the writing's on the wall and
you'll start playing that Unholy song
Unholy uh at the body shop and then all
your fat kids you come in every night
and all the feel your fat trans kids are
just singing at that body shop and we're
worshiping Satan
and you go yes this is my fan and love
them love them that's your family
love them and they'll sit in chairs they
break the chair the chair will fall down
you know we're gonna get another chair
for you you're gonna be as big as you
want to be because it's beautiful and
that's what that's what I really think
we have to do because otherwise I'm just
getting I'm getting a
I'm getting tired of it I'm getting
tired of uh all the fighting so to
either either read the kids the books or
just let them what's the worst that's
gonna have they only live with you for
18 years
they live with you for 18 years then you
can deny knowing them you can say I
don't really know them
you know you just be like tell me they
died be like they died just sad it was
leukemia
really it's leukemia because we see them
on social media I think they're a fat
trans Satanist oh well yeah well yeah we
tried to avoid that what'd you do we
read a chapter The Lion the Witch and
the Wardrobe but you know I don't like
reading myself so I uh
we got to a point where we just had to
kind of throw the towel in and uh you
know
they're happy let them be goblins you
know but what would help this probably
to be honest what would help this is a
little bit of a war uh to to get
everyone into could shape everybody out
it's not where it's hard I have a
trainer it's hard very hard if you count
calories we need a war
we need a [__] War
and I didn't you know in the beginning
when I'm like we need to be nuked
everyone's got people get so mad at that
but that's okay
um but what I mean is that
coming out you know like just like just
imagine the politicians speaking the
great speeches like we we were nuked
we were nuked but
but we're gonna build back better and
stronger and we nuked them of course
we're gonna nuke them we all nuked each
other
but but there's a few areas of the
country that are livable
and we're all going to try to figure
that out and we've lost about maybe 80
million people and that's sad but we who
cut some dead weight here
we cut some dead weight a lot of fat
trans satanists were taken out with that
nuke
and the people mad at them ironically
both groups were gone and hey you know
it's just one of those things where
we're back now there's a few regions of
the country that are back and um I just
hope that I hope everyone's okay
and you know we're just let's let's have
a moment of silence
I mean I just think would be a good
reset that's all and again I'm not
I'm not calling for it I'm just saying
as an observer I don't see how we get
out of this without
some like Alien Invasion something has
to happen here something has to happen
because this is like a [__] we're in
a we're in a we're in an unending
nightmare this country it's an unending
nightmare of like
just you know insane
people and there's so much money in it
that's the other there's so much money
in being nuts there's just so much money
in being crazy that's the real problem
it's like if I gave my mother a lot of
money to be a schizo like I'm like yeah
give her more money like if that was a
business that's where we're at now where
it's like the craziest people are making
Oodles of money pumping [__] crazy
insane [__] so
read to the kids come see me live uh I
have a great I mean if this hour
just kind of wet your whistle I have a
really good Valentine's Day message for
the couples
so I mean
if you come see me live it's mainly
about dating
so this is just what I do on here but to
be honest with you
I'm dating
it's about dating
The Body Shop
she took the fastest shot now she had a
stroke
Raleigh North Carolina I'm going to be
there soon I could be there in a few
days
The Improv Tucson Arizona Phoenix
Arizona Monterey California Vancouver
Canada Napa California Palm Beach Palm
Beach Palm Beach Inglewood Huntington
New Brunswick Huntington New York
Tim dilloncomedy.com for all of the
great things I hope this wasn't too
negative I some people will probably
enjoy this some people won't but that's
okay
because we live in hell and I don't know
what to do except telling you like read
your kid like tales of the Fourth Grade
Nothing
lion witch in the wardrobe like there's
great literature out there Dickens read
your kids Dickens imagine imagine if
everyone that was mad at Sam Smith had
to read their kid Charles Dickens
wouldn't that be great
the change starts with you
really the change starts with you so
it's ultimately a message of Hope
there are so many things in this episode
where you could clip and end my career
[Laughter]
from different angles
like there's so many things you could
just clip me longing for the country to
get nuked me saying that everyone is
going to be a fat trans Satanist
out of context this seems really bad in
context it's a beautiful love letter to
a bright future if we have the if we're
lucky enough to get nuked if we're lucky
enough to be attacked by a nuclear power
I believe the future is bright absent
that I don't know I don't know truly I
don't know
and I believe this is probably the way
that like really rich guys are talking
in like places you know like these you
have these mountain cabin Retreats they
all go to
I think there's probably some of them
smoking a cigar going we need something
here
you know we need a little something to
happen yeah you know 911's worn off in
her memory hasn't it Bob oh they've
forgotten about that they don't even
watch the memorial anymore I know I know
and what are they doing everyone's fat
and they're all satanists now we're
supposed to be satanists if we've always
been thin everyone on the Yale rowing
team we were all satanists and we're all
thin we're in great shape now fat people
are satanists and they're trans I don't
even know what that is oh you know what
it is Bob remember when we went to Latin
America yeah yeah okay I get it now I
get it now we had that time in Brazil
anyway
um Tim dilloncomedy.com uh everybody and
uh let's see if we've done the hour oh
we're at an hour 34.
it flies by it flies by when you love
what you do it flies by when you love
what you do
and nobody loves what they do more than
me so when you love what you do you know
you don't work a day in your life and um
all right well
good night everybody read to the kids